quite often in Greek mythology Hades is
mistaken as the god of death and though
it is something that he would naturally
deal with be in the rule of the
underworld it is the primordial deity
known as Thanatos who is death
personified Thanatos doesn't play a huge
part in Greek mythology but he was
amongst the first generation of gods to
exist his mother being Nix and his
father Erebus night and darkness like
many of the primordial beings they're
quite often thought to represent
concepts rather than taken physical form
Thanatos of course representing the
concept of death but with that being
said
Thanatos is somewhat of an exception he
can be seen making a few rare
appearances in early Greek artwork often
appearing as a man in a dark cloak with
wings sometimes even willed in a scythe
a figure that resembles what we consider
today to be the Grim Reaper perhaps a
dark and fallen angel when deities are
associated with death it's quite normal
for them to be assumed as evil death is
something that we ultimately cannot
avoid and the fear of the inevitable is
why these figures become somewhat
demonized but as is the case with the
majority of these deities Thanatos
included they are far from evil
Thanatos himself was thought to be the
spirit of non-violent death known for
his gentle touch similar to that of his
brother hypnosis the primal deity of
sleep it was Thanatos his sister's the
karez who were the primordial spirits of
slaughter and disease often seen as
bloodthirsty and haunting figures
Thanatos is remainin siblings were just
as powerful Eris the goddess of strife
nemesis the goddess of retribution a
party the goddess of deception and
Charon the boatman of the underworld
when performing his duties much like
Hades
Thanatos was unbias and indiscriminate
which men he was hated by both men and
gods as in Thanatos his eyes death could
not be bargained with he was merciless
of those whose time had come to an end
but his touch of death was quick and
painless death may have been considered
as unavoidable especially for mortals
but there are a few occasions where
individuals manage to outsmart Thanatos
and essentially cheat death for a brief
period of time the King Sisyphus was a
figure known for his guy
trickery but having betrayed the gods he
was punished by Zeus Thanatos was
ordered to take the king to the
underworld and chained him there as his
time amongst eleven had come to an end
when the two eventually reached the
underworld the king asked Thanatos if he
could demonstrate how the chains would
work Thanatos was merciful enough to
grant the king this one last request
but Sisyphus seized the opportunity
trapped in theaters in his own chains
and escaped in death with Thanatos bound
in the underworld no one on earth could
die and this particularly angered the
god Ares what good was a war if his
opponents could not die and so he
intervened traveling to the underworld
free in Thanatos and handing over King
Sisyphus in the process this story does
show us that Thanatos is by no means
evil he despised compassion towards the
king which doesn't turn lead to him
being tricked and we can potentially
view this compassion as either a
strength or weakness talentos did also
have a brief confrontation with the hero
Heracles when he was asked to bring the
princess known as our cestus to the
underworld
Heracles fought the god of death
eventually driving him away during the
Trojan War Thanatos was summoned to
return the body of the demigod known as
Sarpedon whose father Zeus wanted his
son's body to be taken to his native
land of lie SIA Sarpedon was an allied
to the Trojans and fought fiercely until
the last year of the war when he would
be killed by Patroclus
despite being responsible for
engineering the war
Zeus lamented his son's death and he
could not let his son's body be
disgraced on the battlefield he ordered
the god apollo to retrieve his son's
body and once apollo had done so he
would then give the body to Thanatos and
hypnose who would take the body to Lysa
and give Sarpedon the hero's burial he
deserved talentos of course accepted
this task but not because they'd been
given to him by Zeus but because honour
and death was his solemn duty in the
later eras the transition of life to
death in the Elysium Fields was seen as
a more appealing option than before and
with this came a change in Thanatos his
appearance he was now seen as an
extremely beautiful god similar to that
of eros and the other wing and gods of
Greek mythology during this period of
time there were a number of different
depictions of Thanatos in some he was
seen as an infant sleeping in the arms
of his MA
the Knicks and in others he could be
seen carrying upside-down torches
symbolizing a life that had been
extinguished I personally have a great
deal of respect for date he's like
Thanatos who perform these thankless
roles they often go unnoticed and when
people do eventually pay attention
they're very quick to demonize them
without much thought at all Thanatos was
known for his gentle touch and his
embrace was almost welcomed unlike some
of his sisters the form of death that
followed was quick and painless
Thanatos is of God I'd compare to Hades
who's quite often mistakenly associated
with the Christian devil leading people
to believe that he must be evil there
are those who would compare Thanatos to
the Grim Reaper and though Thanatos may
have been one of the many influences of
the Grim Reaper they are most certainly
not the same person there is no glory in
what Thanatos and the other day tease
associated with death do but the role
they perform is crucial in maintaining
the cycle of life and death I hope you
guys enjoyed taking a look at another
one of the lesser mentioned deities in
Greek mythology if you did and you have
any thoughts and Thanatos then please
let me know in the comments below but as
always I've been your host mythology in
fiction explained